- What is that joke
that you told recently at the office?
I said, I wish I was high on potenuse.
(class laughing)
- These nuts were low against your chin.
(upbeat instrumental music)
(man laughing)
- That's not it.
That's not it.
That's not the punch line.
Make fun of the burns.
Make fun of the robot voice.
- Sir, I don't know.
- Come on.
(audience cheering)
- All right.
Thank you, sir.
- All right!
- All right, how's everybody?
How's everybody doing?
(audience cheering)
All right.
And you guys can all hear me okay?
- [Audience] Yeah.
- I know this guy can right here.
Boy, this guy's ears are so big
he's laughing at jokes
from the Yuck Yuck Club
up all the way on the other side of town.
(audience laughing)
All right.
And you, sir, you you're doing okay?
Right. And you're getting enough to eat?
Is that even possible?
(audience laughing)
Thank you, sir.
Folks, I'm sorry.
I'm gonna get everybody tonight.
I'm gonna, nobody is safe.
I'm getting everybody,
except for you, sir.
I'm gonna leave you alone.
Just like your date did tonight.
Hello!
(audience laughing)
All right.
Okay, who is next?
Who is next?
Hey ma'am, I get it.
You have breasts, okay?
(audience laughing)
Geez.
I mean, look at this chick over here.
Her cleavage is giving the Grand Canyon
in an inferiority complex.
(audience laughing)
- You skipped me.
- Who's, who's talking right now?
- Do me.
- Yeah. Hey, man.
Look at that pink shirt you got on there.
Wow. Where'd you get that?
QueerTshirts.com?
(audience laughing)
- It's in support of
breast cancer awareness.
I am gay though.
- Okay.
- Go for it.
I can take it.
- Hmm?
Oh yeah.
Yeah. No. Hey.
Yeah, don't you worry about that, man.
(man chuckling)
Gloves are coming off.
Okay?
Right there. Right there.
What's with the three drinks, man?
Alcoholic much?
(audience laughing)
- This is my pain medication.
- Oh (beep), 'course it is.
It's your pain medication.
'Cause he is in pain.
Right now.
- Make fun of the burns.
(man sighing)
- Make, make fun of the,
what did you say?
Because here's the problem, sir,
is it's really dark in here,
and sorry, are you burned?
'Cause I can't make it out.
Thanks so much, ma'am,
for illuminating him.
Thank you.
That's, I appreciate that.
Oh, those burns?
- Make fun of the robot voice.
- Sir. I don't know.
- Come on. I can take it.
- Okay. Well now, you know what?
I feel like.
- Or the wheelchair
- Look, sir, there is nothing funny
about you being in a wheelchair,
and we can all.
- Oh, but there is something
funny about me being fat?
- All right.
All right, fine. Fine.
I've got it. I've got it.
I'm doing it. I'm doing it.
I just didn't wanna go after this guy,
'cause I didn't want him
to kill me in my dreams.
Like, like Freddy Kruger.
(audience scoffing)
- Oh, come on.
- 'Cause, no?
'Cause you how Freddy
Kruger's face is burned off?
That's not?
(man crying)
- You (beep).
- He said he could take it!
That's what he said!
- I thought I could, but I can't.
- How is on me?
How do we even know if
he's crying right now?
(audience booing)
Well, I don't know that sound.
It just sounds like an electronic sound.
Are we?
- The tears.
(audience booing)
They burn!
- He said he could take it!
(audience booing)
(glass crashing)
(audience cheering)
- The right triangle's longest side
is called the hypotenuse.
And it's this side here.
- Hey.
- [Teacher] See,
the longest one.
- I wish I were high
on pot-nuse.
(man giggling)
- I wish I was high on pot-nuse.
(class laughing)
- Okay, okay.
Mr. Morris. It's very funny.
It's very funny,
but let's get back to the lesson.
And you can see the longest one
where it goes from this point.
- That was my joke.
- I know, man. That was hilarious
- [Teacher] Of a triangle.
I've labeled them here, A, B and C.
- No, but I mean, I said that.
I said it.
I said that!
- Please!
Please, Mr. Jackson, keep
your comments to yourself.
Thank you.
Now the hypotenuse.
(class laughing)
Mr. Morris, you really got me on that one.
Oh, so great.
Oh, oh Principal Martel!
Principal Martel!
Come here, come here, come here.
Tell Principal Martel what you said, Troy.
- Oh, she was talking about the hypotenuse
and I said, "I wish I
was high on pot-nuse."
(class laughing)
I'm sorry.
He likes it.
Principal Martel's, cool.
- Ooh, that's very funny.
- Principal Martel,
Principal Martel!
I said that!
- Mr. Jackson, that is enough!
- But I said it first.
- Oh Mr. Iglesias, Mr. Iglesias.
Come in. Come in.
(class in awe)
- Yeah. What's up, peoples?
- Fluffy.
- Comedian, Gabriel Iglesias
is touring the local schools today
for a charity he's working on.
Tell him what you said.
- I wish I was high on pot-nuse.
(class laughing)
- Oh my god!
That is clever.
That is clever. Very funny.
Very funny.
- [Morris] Right?
- No
No, no.
- Thanks. Thanks.
- No, no, Mr. Iglesias,
Mr. Iglesias, I'm your biggest fan.
That was my joke.
- You know, it's not really cool, buddy,
to take credit for other people's jokes.
Hey listen, funny stuff.
I'm doing this big tour right now,
you wanna see about maybe
we could talk about you opening?
I need an opener.
- Oh, sure.
- What do you think? Is that okay?
- Of course, of course.
- Yeah?
- What?
(class in awe)
- Talent, man.
- It's nice to meet.
Thanks so much.
- That's like a Richard Pryor.
Get over here, man.
Come on.
- Richard Pryor!
- He deserved it.
All right,
so across from the longest
side is a 90 degree angle.
- Good thing I've got a 90 degree dangle!
- Joe, stop it!
You will never be Troy!
- Why are you trying to be like Troy?
Dick!
- Et tu, nerdy girl?
- So, the hypotenuse,
(class laughing)
- What the (beep) is going on?
- I'm gonna piss my pants.
I'm gonna piss my pants right here.
Oh my god!
Oh!
- Thank you.
Mike!
- Cody.
- Yeah.
Hey, how are man?
- What's up, man?
- Good to see.
Hey, I'm glad I ran into you.
What is that joke that you
told recently at the office?
Everybody is just like
giggling about it all the time
and I haven't heard it yet.
- Oh gosh. Okay.
All right, it goes like this.
Yeah, so there's this woman
(man giggling)
Dang.
- I'm sorry.
- Good audience.
- Sorry, I love it already.
I love it already.
(man laughing)
- Awesome, okay. Well this should go well.
So there's this woman
and she goes to her doctor.
- She goes to the doctor!
(man laughing)
This is already funny.
It's already funny.
- No, I haven't even
gotten to the setup yet.
(man laughing)
So she goes to her doctor and she,
she says to her doctor, kiss me.
(man laughing)
No, that's not it.
That's not it.
That's not, not, not the punchline.
(man laughing)
- You gotta stop, man.
You're killing me over here.
- You,
I don't know if you
think the joke is over,
but it's not.
It's actually just starting.
(man laughing)
Okay, so I'm just gonna speed it up.
So she says to her doctor, kiss me,
and he says, I can't, it
would be unprofessional.
(man laughing)
No.
No, not even close.
She says,
he says that would be unprofessional.
And then she says,
she keeps asking him,
and he says, no, no, no.
That was three times like that.
(man laughing)
Finally at the end she says,
kiss me.
And he says,
I shouldn't even be having
sex with you right now.
- Then what happens?
- I don't, I don't know.
Then I guess she,
she probably sued him for malpractice.
(man laughing)
- Sued him for malpractice.
- So you know that wasn't,
that wasn't the punchline?
- That wasn't the punchline?
- No, the punch line.
- There's more?
- No, there's not more.
(man laughing)
- There's more than the joke?
- No, there's actually less.
- What, you turned it around.
- No, there's.
- You turned it around.
- The joke.
(man laughing)
The joke was,
the punchline was the only
part that you didn't laugh at.
(man laughing)
- What the?
You got me!
- You got me.
You're doing a joke the whole time!
You were doing a weird
character the whole time.
- Oh my god, yes. Yes.
I love the malpractice stuff.
The malpractice punchline is hilarious!
- So you weren't doing character?
- What character?
What character?
- This is some crazy shit.
(moody instrumental music)
- Vince, I,
I have that quarterly
analysis that you asked for.
- I had a quarter of
these nuts on your chin.
(man clearing throat)
- Right.
It's just that I wanted to review
some of these numbers with you.
It seems like our earnings are low
against our original projections.
- These nuts were low against your chin.
- You know, Vince,
if you ever need to talk
to me about something,
I'm more than happy to listen.
- These nuts will be more than happy
to rest against your chin.
- Hey, look, you've been doing
this for about a week now
and it was kind of funny at first.
- These nuts were kind of
funny against your chin.
- Vincent, I'm worried about you.
- I was worried about
these nuts on your chin.
- Man, seriously.
(man sighing)
- These nuts were seriously on your chin.
- Mr. Graham,
I just got a call from St. Mary's Hospital
and your parents were in
a serious car accident.
I'm so sorry, but your mother is dead,
(somber piano music)
and your father is on life support.
- These nuts were supporting
life on your chin.
- Oh my god!
- Sorry, Amber.
Vince, you gotta stop it.
Your mother just passed away.
- These nuts passed away on your chin.
- No, they didn't.
They didn't.
Vince,
listen you gotta leave here right now
and go be with your dad.
This could be the last time
that you get to see him.
- This'll be the last time
I get to see my nuts on your chin.
- God dammit, Vincent!
Your father might be dying!
- These nuts might be dying on your chin!
(loud smacking)
- God dammit, Vince!
Snap the (beep) out of it!
Your mother is dead.
Right.
- You're right.
- You okay?
You're back?
- Yeah, I don't know what came over me.
- It's all right, Vince.
- It's all good,
'cause it worked in every situation.
- I know. I know.
- And it's always, it was just so funny.
- Well, it wasn't,
it wasn't that funny.
- It was funny.
- It really wasn't that funny, Vince.
- Really funny.
- I would not go so far to
say it was really funny.
Vince.
- It was funny.
- But it wasn't though.
- It was.
- It wasn't.
- Agree to disagree. It's funny.
- Okay.
- It's funny.
- One more time,
I'm just gonna go on record of saying
it wasn't really that funny.
- I'm gonna go see my dad.
(upbeat piano music)
It was funny.
- It wasn't that funny.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- Dad?
Stay with me.
Dad, I love you.
(support beeping)
- And I love these nuts on your chin.
(machine flat lining)
(moody piano music)
These nuts on your chin.
(man wailing)
(phone ringing)
(man laughing)
- Cool, ya man.
Oh yeah, certainly.
Oh hey, I gotta go.
Yeah, Terry out.
- Terry, how you doing, man?
- Hey, pretty good, Gabe.
Oh, got something on your shirt.
- Not today, Terry.
(moody instrumental music)
- Looks like Gabe's come out to play.
You do have something
on your shirt though.
- No, I don't.
- Yeah, you kind of do.
- No, I'm pretty sure I don't.
- Got a clean shirt at my desk
if you want me to get it for you.
- Don't see why that would be necessary.
- Well, because the shirt
you have on right now,
it's not clean.
- Except for that it is.
- Me, I have a clean shirt.
- Oh?
- You,
you have some shmutz on your jammy-jam.
- No, there is no shmutz on my jammy-jam.
(moody instrumental music)
- You know what, why don't
I just get it for you?
- Yeah, why don't you do that?
- Yeah.
(man clearing throat)
And, there we go.
- Did you get it?
(man laughing)
- I almost got ya!
- Yeah.
- I was that close!
- Almost, almost.
- I mean, I'm thinking,
damn, he's good.
(men chuckling)
But you know what the funny thing is?
- What's that?
- Now, I guess from
when I dabbed your shirt
with the paper towel,
and I'm not playing the game right now,
but I actually I must have
got some paper towel fuzz
on your shirt, so.
(dramatic instrumental music)
- Hey, how long has Karen
been wearing her hair up like that?
(dramatic instrumental music)
(dramatic music continues)
- Shh.
(dramatic instrumental music continues)
- I don't want you have
to go through that,
and I'm sorry it happened.
- Hey Terry, what's going on?
- Nothing.
- Having a good morning?
- Yeah.
- I'm having a
(beep) terrific morning.
- Great.
- Hope there's nothing
on my shirt
'cause I can't look down.
- Oh no, dude.
We're not doing that right now, okay?
There's nothing on your shirt.
No one cares about your shirt.
Everything's not about you.
I'm trying to have a conversation
with Karen right now,
so?
- You okay, Terry?
- Just pisses me off.
(Velcro ripping)
(man sighing)
(phone buzzing)
(dramatic instrumental music)
(man wailing)
- I got it. I got it.
(man laughing manically)
There's no way you're gonna know.
Oh yeah.
Yeah. I do have shmutz.
There's shmutz all over me now.
He can't deny that!
Terry's not gonna know what hit him!
I will win!
(man laughing manically)
I win!
(dramatic music)
(woman singing)
What? What happened?
- Terry died!
(dramatic music)
(woman singing)
(moody instrumental music)
- Hey Terry,
it's Gabe.
I just wanted to let you know that,
that you didn't get me, Terry.
You didn't get me because
on the day that you died
there was shmutz on my shirt.
So guess who wins the game, Terry?
I do!
I win!
(man laughing manically)
You lose!
(dramatic instrumental music)
(man yelling)
(woman singing)
(dramatic music)
No,
Terry!
(man weeping)
He flicked me.
(dramatic instrumental music)
(upbeat funky music)
♪ All I want is ♪
♪ But I don't need you ♪